President Trump is expected to address
ways to combat terrorism during a
two-day stop in Saudi Arabia mr. Trump
will also visit holy sites in Jerusalem
and the Vatican on this trip that's
followed by a NATO summit in Brussels
he'll wrap up with the g7 meeting in
Sicily major Garrett is with the
president in Riyadh the Saudi capital
major good morning good morning the
president's arrival here in Saudi Arabia
came with what can be best - described
as a few logistical difficulties the
Saudis literally rolled out the red
carpet but were a bit late with the
final touches leaving Air Force One
briefly without stairs for the president
to descend then the staircase and the
carpet did not align causing a second
delay in fervent hopes that these
problems were not a metaphor for the
president's first trip out on to the
world stage President Trump and First
Lady Melania then met Saudi King Salman
and made their way to an airport
reception over ceremonial cups of Arabic
coffee the two leaders exchanged
pleasantries with mr. Trump at one point
asking King Salman if he spent much time
in New York the king 81 does not travel
extensively the two leaders wrote in the
presidential limousine to meetings where
President Trump will push for Saudi
leadership and bringing Gulf nations
into a new security alliance to
challenge Iran and combat Isis and
al-qaeda affiliates throughout the
region there will be a summit here to
create what the White House now calls a
new Arab NATO part of the president's
emphasis on security and commerce over
human rights and democracy the president
will also deliver a speech to the
Islamic world that speech being written
by Stephen Miller one of the two
principal authors of the president's
first Muslim travel ban Anthony major
Garrett traveling with the president in
Saudi Arabia thanks